c'est l'un des bâtiments les mieux
gardés de tully vie
aujourd'hui catherine et son ami
tunisienne rokhaya doivent se soumettre
à une série de contrôles avant de
visiter le musée du bardo
[Musique]
le dispositif date de deux mois à peine
depuis l'attentât qui a frappé le musée
le 18 mars dernier des hommes en armes
assure la sécurité de ce bâtiment devenu
aussi un lieu de mémoire
series à l'entrée cette stèle rappelle
le nom des 22 victimes de l' attaque
parmi elles quatre touristes français
c'est trop bizarre
pour cette bretonne installée en tunisie
depuis qu'elle est à la retraite visiter
aujourd'hui cette collection de
mosaïques unique au monde est aussi un
acte militant
après l'attentât la fréquentation du
musée a baissé d'à peine 10 %
certains ont eu peur d'y retourner mais
d'autre part engagement ou par curiosité
ont décidé de venir quand même
solidarité
solidarité avec le peuple tunisien
voilà c'est tout j'ai envie de leur dire
vous ne réussirez pas nous impressionner
et j'espère que en france vous
continuerez à venir
nombreux
si le musée a rouvert ses portes les
blessures de l'attentât elles ne sont
pas toutes refermées
elles sont même bien visible dans
certaines salles et aussi des adeptes
voilà la
regarde les impacts de des balles tirées
lors de l'attentât du bardo
ce affreux affreux d'imaginer ça
pour ne jamais oublier les autorités
tunisiennes ont décidé de ne pas réparer
les vitrines et laisse volontairement
ses impacts exposés à la vue du public
sur
je vous en prie
vive la tunisie vive le pardon
au revoir merci merci
depuis l'attentât du bardo les
réservations des touristes ont une vie
ont baissé de moitié mais des français
ont décidé de partir quand même pour
certains ce serait même une manière de
soutenir ce pays devenu une cible des
jihadistes
moteur de l'économie le tourisme
tunisien peut-il se remettre de cette
attaque les autorités ont-elles les
moyens de garantir la sécurité des
vacanciers
[Musique]
voyage dans une jeune démocratie dont
les jasmins doivent aujourd'hui défier
des kalachnikovs
[Musique]
l'île de djerba au sud du pays
c'est l'une des destinations phares de
la tunisie
en cette fin de mois d'avril le soleil
est déjà au rendez vous et à première
vue les touristes aussi
[Musique]
il est 17h au fiesta beach club comme
tous les jours c'est l'heure de la danse
autour de la piscine
20 % de touristes en moins cette année
mais l'hôtel tourner quand même
ici pierre et sophie sont des habitués
comme l'année dernière ce couple
d'enseignants est venu avec louise et
margot leurs deux filles pour eux rien
n'a changé dans le club par rapport à la
saison précédente
on est content on a vu cela qu'à l'est
donc on est très content d'avoir trouvé
la chaleur et puis on profite on profite
de la piscine la mer
mais à cause de l'attentât la famille a
quand même décidé de changer un peu ses
habitudes après on appel à des sous
ensembles de pas sortir de l'eau
tellement qu
ils ont été plus ensemble aux ibères
voile on a des enfants donc on n'a pas
envie de risquer quoi que ce soit même
sillon même s'il n'ya pas vraiment de
risque
aucune excursions pour cette année ils
passeront toutes leurs journées
et aussi leur soirée à l'intérieur de
l'hôtel
et ça tombe bien c'est justement le
principe de ce genre de club cette nuit
c'est le spectacle bollywood
comme pierre et sophie cette semaine là
la plupart des clients de l'hôtel ne
mettront pas le nez dehors
[Applaudissements]
mais malgré l'attentât d'autres sont
bien décidés à découvrir un peu le pays
comme florence et emmanuel ce jour là
ils seront les seuls à s'aventurer avec
leurs deux fils en dehors du périmètre
du club
pour leur premier séjour en tunisie ils
souhaitent visiter le souk de djerba
apparemment pour eux les risques
d'attentât ne sont pas vraiment une
préoccupation
c'est nettement plus peur de la conduite
des taxis notamment
que du risque d'attentats
si on avait la moindre crainte on serait
pas là en famille avec nos enfants
sur le trajet nous découvrons avec eux
un dispositif de sécurité renforcé qui
n'existait pas avant l' attaque du bardo
le dernier attentat a eu lieu ici à
djerba il visait la ghriba la principale
synagogue
bilan 14 morts parmi les touristes
allemands c'était en 2002
aujourd'hui toutes les routes de l'île
sont filtrés par des barrages chaque
voiture est arrêtée
certaines sont fouillés de fond en
comble
c'est marquant la première fois qu'on
arrive sur un barrage mais après on s'y
habitue très bien et ça fait pas du tout
peur
malgré la présence des forces de l'ordre
qui jugent rassurantes arrivées au souk
ils se sentent un peu seuls
on revient repasse pas en touristes à
l'horizon
des dizaines de marchands attendent les
clients devant leur stand sans grand
espoir
mais avec le sourire
à des taux y'a rien famille royale est
rien
c'est resté comme ça ils vont manger
bientôt le cahier augmenterait à cause
de quoi à cause des pathogènes je
risque pas de travail pas d'argent pas
tout
cas qu'il est déjà pour
ce samedi là les 35 euros que pierre
dépensera chez ce commerçant seront sa
seule vente de la journée on participe à
l'économie locale
et puis on veut rapporter des choses
vraies réel authentique merci
si les clubs de vacances parviennent
encore à attirer des occidentaux ce sont
les petites mains du tourisme comme ces
marchands qui subissent de plein fouet
les conséquences de l'attentât les
vacanciers enfermés dans les hôtels ne
parviennent plus jusqu'à eux par mesure
de sécurité la plupart des excursions
ont été annulés
[Musique]
dans certaines régions du pays la
situation est encore plus difficile
comme ici en banlieue de tunis à sidi
bou saïd
avec ses petites ruelles pavées et ses
maisons typiques le village est un
emblème du tourisme tunisien
5000 habitants mais jusqu'à 15000
visiteurs par jour en haute saison
habituellement en cette période de
l'année muji le cafetier ne sait même
plus où les asseoir
les groupes étaient là avec leur guide
et touba il fallait attendre entre cinq
et dix minutes pour avoir une place de
libre
là les gens passaient même quinze
minutes pour pouvoir aller aux toilettes
à
aurélie
c'est triste si vous regardez ses prises
tout cet espace la visite pour 40 à
cause de deux inspectrices
du jour au lendemain il a dû licencier
80 % de son personnel
il y avait un plongeur un grand toit
risques pour servir des cafés les jeux
et aux un responsable
qui était responsable des chichas bien
vient qui s'occupait des poils est en
fait quand notre intranet il avait un
qui s'occuperait de toilette en plus des
deux serveurs et y compris moi voilà on
est moi un chiffrement on se partage les
tâches
à sidi bou saïd la baisse de la
fréquentation a été rapide et
spectaculaire
la raison de la disparition des
touristes nous allons la comprendre en
nous rendant à quelques kilomètres de là
[Musique]
on arrive devant le port de la goulette
slim bendjaballah et agents de voyages
jusqu'au 18 mars dernier tous les
mercredis il accueillait sur ce qu'est
des milliers de visiteurs étrangers qui
débarquait des bateaux de croisière
[Musique]
je rêve de voir les deux bateaux ici et
l'autre bakker constat là bas est mais
c'est ici et pour le mans tours de
l'autre côté il ya les chameaux ici il
ya l'animation le folklore il ya les
touristes qui descendent pour aller
faire les formalités de police est allée
prennent leur bus avec le numéro là
normalement on devrait avoir plus que 80
bus pour les excursions
mais depuis l'attentât plus rien les
victimes du bardo venait presque toutes
ces bateaux alors les compagnies de
croisières ont décidé de suspendre leurs
escales à la goulette privant tunis et
sa région de la majeure partie de ces
touristes
pour les faire revenir slim travaille
régulièrement avec le directeur du port
ils doivent revoir entièrement les
règles de sécurité
sécuriser tout risque à 2 pourtant en
dehors du port il faut assurer la
sécurité des sites et des voix routier
reliant le pôle aussi l'enjeu améliorer
la sécurité et surtout le faire savoir
pour rassurer les compagnies de
croisières qui ont déserté le pays
on va faire un cd comment ça a été un
exemple mais et bardos comment il était
quand même comment il est maintenant les
sites de captage comment c'était comment
ils sont maintenant c'est les routes
aussi en coordination avec tout le monde
avec
ministère de l'intérieur le tourisme
tout le monde on va préparer ses cd on
va le présenter au ma compagne car nos
amis amateurs de venir il suffit que le
premier navire a accosté au port de la
goulette et
faire revenir les touristes c'est donc
aussi une question d'image et de
communication
peut-être est-ce pour cela que la police
tunisienne a accepté la présence
exceptionnelle de notre caméra lors d'un
exercice d'entraînement
à la marsa une banlieue chic de tunis le
commissaire bauchi chef de la brigade
touristique a réuni ses troupes devant
le commissariat
son unité existe depuis 15 ans elle a
intensifié ses contrôles depuis l'
attaque du bardo elle organise ce jour
là une simulation pour vérifier le
niveau de sécurité d'un hôtel très
fréquenté par les étrangers
hawat infiltré pour voir si la
surveillance de l'entrée par la plage
est suffisante aux
lattois c'est de tester l'entrée
principale a essayé de passer et de
prendre l'ascenseur en faisant rentrer
une arme une armée avec une arme
leur objectif vérifier que les agents de
sécurité de l'hôtel sont capables
d'intercepter un intrus qui tentent de
s'introduire dans leur établissement
le danger peut venir de partout sur la
plage c'est ce jeune homme qui se prête
à l'exercice il est rapidement repéré et
neutralisé puis conformément à la
procédure les agents contacter la police
une fois prévenu le commissaire et ses
hommes interviennent pour évacuer le
faux suspect
s'agit-il d'un vrai test en situation
réelle ou d'un scénario préparé à
l'avancé avec l'hôtelier pour notre
caméra
difficile de le savoir
le commissaire bauchi nous assure de sa
bonne foi
[Musique]
l'intervention doit être en condition
réelle
rien ne doit être faux hors de question
l'intrus auraient été repérés dans cette
salle le pc sécurité de l'hôtel grâce à
des caméras à détecteur de mouvements
l'employé qui souhaite rester anonyme
nous affirme que c'est elle qui a donné
l' alerte
je les trouvais bizarre maman cher a dit
alors tout de suite j'ai donné l alerte
aux agents de sécurité par téléphone
on m'a toujours dit au moindre doute tu
prévient tout de suite
quant au second complice qui porte une
caméra discrète il était censé
introduire une arme par l'entrée
principale
il sera repéré grâce au détecteur de
métaux de l'hôtel
nous avons contacté une vingtaine
d'hôteliers dans la région de tunis et à
djerba ils nous ont tous confirmé avoir
subi ce type de contrôle dans les
dernières semaines
lors de notre tournage cet hôtel 5
étoiles at il été choisi au hasard et
tous les établissements ont-ils une
sécurité aussi efficace peut-être pas
[Musique]
sérieux on alors
mais selon les autorités ces exercices
permettrait justement de déceler les
failles et d'améliorer le dispositif
[Musique]
c'est ce que nous a confirmé le
directeur français de cet autre
établissement de luxe david pierrât a
déjà été soumis aux mêmes types de
contrôles
il a décidé d'améliorer la sécurité de
son hôtel
d'entrée de l'hôtel on met des process
en route un petit peu plus pointu alors
on n'est pas un ambassades poussé par
contre ils répondent se doit d'assurer
la société nos clients et puis le bardo
et eu peut-être plus une prise de
conscience des choses qui peuvent
arriver alors on fait nécessaire
malgré les 123 caméras de surveillance
de son hôtel il y aurait encore une
faille tous les accès ne serait pas dans
le champ des caméras ses employés d'une
société de sécurité sont venus pour les
expertises et il faut qu'il ya une
caméra qui voit sa
taxe et
observe tout l'espace
angles morts
des équipements pour surveiller
dissuader ou rassurer
les tunisiens l'ont bien compris
investir dans la sécurité est aussi un
moyen de changer l'image du pays accusé
de négligence lors de l'attaqué du bardo
les autorités ont aussi commandé en
urgence une nouvelle campagne de
publicité
dans les rues de paris et des
principales capitales européennes
ces photos de célébrités affichant leur
soutien à la tunisie
certaines de ces personnalités comme
bertrand delanoë ont des liens avec le
pays une manière de présenter le
tourisme tunisien comme une cause à
défendre une forme d'engagement
à tunis nous retrouvons l'homme qui a
inspiré cette campagne il n'est pas
publicitaire mais journalistes et
militants politiques
kerim bouzouita s'est fait connaître au
moment de la révolution de 2011 à
l'époque ils admettent un blog et se
battait pour la liberté et la démocratie
pour lui après l'attentât le tourisme
serait devenu une cause politique venir
en vacances en tunisie sera le meilleur
moyen de lutter contre la terreur
le soir de la tacc cet habitué des
réseaux sociaux lance spontanément une
campagne de soutien à son pays qui
remporte un succès immédiat
auprès des attentats du bardo c'était le
18 mars alors le 18 mars vers
22h30 à quelqu'un qui publie la photo
d'un jeune serbe un écriteau et il
s'engage il dit à will come tenez ja
dessin me viendrait en tunisie cet été
donc je joue un coup de bluff je prends
cette photo le rédige un statut et je
dis ça y est la campagne je viendrai en
tunisie c'était était élancé au bout de
quelques jours je voit qu'on a un
million cinq cent mille personnes qui
ont vu des publications de cette page
les médias s'intéressent au buzz et qui
dit gros médias derrière il ya aussi les
stars
le chanteur charles aznavour le joueur
de foot lionel messi est la vedette
américaine lindsay lohan poste
rapidement leur selphy ils sont suivis
par des dizaines de milliers de
personnes dans 120 pays ce succès
inspirent les autorités tunisiennes elle
décide d'utiliser l'idée de kerim et
d'en reprendre les codes pour leur
campagne officielle
le pire des sentiments quand vous êtes
sous le feu des terroristes c'est le
sentiment d'isolement se sentir seul au
monde face à ce fléau qui me suis dit
mme sy et ce qui serai sympa qu'il y ait
un élan de solidarité s'est c'est ça le
vrai but de ceux de cette campagne 30 15
bonsoir les amis vous êtes suis radio
tunisiano terre et vous écoutez contacts
dans l'émission que kerry m'anime sur la
radio nationale tunisienne c'est aussi
de tourisme dont il est question cette
semaine là
sujet
très très brûlant le tourisme en tunisie
pour lui et son invité il faut inventer
un nouveau modèle plus équitable pour
permettre aux régions défavorisées d'où
proviennent la majorité des djihadistes
de bénéficier elles aussi de l'argent du
tourisme faut-il sortir du tourisme
balnéaire de l'hôtellerie pour trouver
d'autres solutions pour relancer le
tourisme et pour aller dans une autre
direction peut-être plus intéressante
même est humainement et économiquement
c'est plutôt aller vers l'intérieur du
pays c'est plutôt voir un petit peu
comment les gens vivent les coutumes les
traditions tout ce qui est gastronomie
en bref faire voir un petit peu un visa
de la tunisie qui est plutôt méconnu
aujourd'hui victimes du terrorisme le
tourisme pourrait selon eux devenir la
meilleure arme pour combattre cet
extrémisme ans
devrait accueillir plus de gens de nos
maisons plus de gens dans leur région
leur faire voir un petit peu comment en
vie le tunisien c'est quelqu'un de très
calme très gentille on n'est pas des
terroristes on n'est pas vraiment 2 de
ce bord extrémistes en édition de ça et
on doit avoir un petit peu ce côté
qu'elmer traîner
une forme de tourisme différentes et
engagé qui n'est encore pratiquée que
par une poignée de voyageurs en tunisie
dans ce mini bus en direction du sud
ouest du pays ils sont une douzaine
tunisien et occidentaux ils partent dans
les montagnes de kasr in une région
totalement délaissé par les agences de
voyage à plus de 300 km de tunis
asma est engagée dans une association
elle a activé ses contacts et dans ce
but tous ou presque se connaissent
dans le groupe gabrielle un étudiant
canadien qui séjourne quelques semaines
dans le pays ces quelques ennemis qu'on
est là catherine aujourd'hui pour le
festival les bergers et les plusieurs
cafés où vous les occidentaux quelle est
la base balbouli des foyers même j'ai
l'impression que quelques-uns
il faut dire que catherine n'a pas bonne
réputation
coller à la frontière algérienne ces
montagnes abrite un maquis djihadistes
d'une soixantaine de combattants qui
circulent entre l'algérie et la tunisie
elles sont le théâtre de nombreux
affrontements qui ont déjà fait plus de
30 morts dans l'armée tunisienne et plus
de 40 chez les rebelles c'est aussi
l'une des zones les plus pauvres du pays
dont est originaire l'un des deux
auteurs de l'attentât du bardo
[Musique]
lorsque gabriel et son groupe arrive la
fête des bergers a déjà commencé
des villageoises chante sur une scène
improvisée au pied des montagnes
celle là même où se cacheraient des
djihadistes ans
pour sécuriser cette fête de village
cette fois ci des militaires et des
policiers armés montent la garde ils
sont presque aussi nombreux que les
occidentaux qui le protège
merci à tous des tracasseries de ce soir
l'organisateur de cet événement adnène
est un enseignant de 40 ans
originaire du village il a eu l'idée
d'utiliser le tourisme pour combattre la
peur
c'est la quatrième édition de ce
festival
malgré le contexte tendu il a décidé de
maintenir cet événement envers et contre
tout ce qui se passe dans les montagnes
ce surtout ceux comme entre ces noirs
ces obscures c'est pas si mist on va pas
dire que tout va bien mais on veut dire
qu'on est là aussi pour pour défendre la
vie la culture la joie la reine ya des
jeunes qui croient
devant notre caméra s'improvise hymne
national tunisien
comme s'ils adressé un message aux
djihadistes tout proche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après un repas partagé et nuit passée
chez l'habitant
le jour se lève sur une mauvaise
nouvelle
le petit groupe devra finalement renoncé
au but de son voyage une excursion
sommet des montagnes avec les bergers
l'armée interdit à aden d'aller plus
loin elle a bouclé la zone
ça devient tourisme chez les militants
c'est un nouveau terme qui se crée dans
les montagnes tunisiennes on va aller
deux ou trois cents mètres d'ici le
groupe est seulement autorisé à aller
voir le troupeau du voisin
sous bonne escorte
il assiste à la tonte artisanale d'un
mouton et profite d'un petit spectacle
de breakdance improvisé par les enfants
des bergers
[Applaudissements]
mais au bout d'à peine une heure les
agents de la garde nationale intervienne
alors il arrive votre chauffeur
il existe que les occidentaux quittent
les lieux au plus vite
vite oui oui on y va
la nuit suivante 10 jihadistes et trois
militaires tunisiens seront tués au
cours d'un affrontement
oui on aime bien dire pour revoir jean
[Musique]
le mini bus repart encadré de voitures
de police
adnène visiblement déçu
il faut aller au delà des problèmes
maintenant l'un des problèmes sur place
pour les affronter on fait pas du
kamikaze mais c'est faisable
renda est une journaliste tunisienne
après ce voyage elle est convaincue que
le tourisme peut lutter contre le
terrorisme
genre y était abandonné depuis depuis
l'indépendance
je pense qu'il est
renton vraiment filles aussi
deux arts culture allez offrir seulement
pour dans cette région il ya rien et
pourquoi cela pose
développer le tourisme à kaffrine ne
sera pas facile
à quelques kilomètres de là nous
découvrons un site à l'abandon
ce pays cela est un vestige romain du
1er siècle l'un des nombreux que compte
la tunisie
très beau et c'est impressionnant que ça
soit conservée comme ça gratuitement
deux mille ans
autrefois exploitées le site est
aujourd'hui à l'abandon
victime de la mauvaise réputation de
kaffrine ce but là a disparu des
itinéraires touristiques
[Musique]
dans l'amphithéâtre romain admet mme
offre à ses invités un spectacle
improvisé chaude le senior le mieux
serait plus là
il faudra encore du temps pour faire
revivre ce lieu chargé de culture et
d'histoire comme madeleine certains
croient encore en l'avenir du tourisme
en tunisie et ont même décidé d'y
investir beaucoup d'argent en cette
période de crise
très loin de kaffrine retour à djerba
lille qui continuent d'accueillir des
touristes a elle aussi connu une baisse
de fréquentation
depuis la révolution tunisienne de 2011
quelques hôtels ont même dû fermer
mais marcus campagne lui vient au
contraire d'investir
bonjour à tous
cet ancien du club bled travaille
aujourd'hui pour le groupe hôtelier
allemand robinson qui possède 23 clubs
de vacances à travers le monde
avec son équipe il s'apprête à ouvrir
ici un nouveau club de vacances dans
quelques jours pour lui la crise que
traverse le tourisme tunisien serait
ponctuelle il s'adresse principalement à
une clientèle allemande après l'attentât
de la ghriba en 2002 qui a tué 14
allemands les touristes sont vite
revenus
il fait le pari qu'il en sera de même
après l'attentât du bardo
ça veut dire que vous espérez dans un an
deux ans trois ans que
exactement
c'est tout à fait normal c'est tout à
fait normal sinon personne n'investit 20
30 millions d'euros dans un nouveau
projet vous vous croyez dans l'avenir du
tourisme ainsi
exactement sinon je serais pas là sinon
on ne serait pas là sinon on règlerait
pas d'autres projets encore qui nous
intéresse beaucoup en tunisie un
discours qui peut paraître étonnant au
lendemain d'un attentat mais cet homme
d'affaires estime que la tunisie ne
présenterait pas de risque particulier
je sais que un événement comme ça peut y
arriver on a manié peut y arriver en
france il y a eu des choses terribles
aussi
madrid à madrid avec les stations des
trains donc ça peut arriver partout les
fous malheureusement et les malades sont
un peu partout dans le monde et ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas de
typique pas un pays qu'il est fou se
rencontrent tous dans un pays
en 20 ans de carrière il a ouvert des
dizaines de clubs à travers le monde
selon lui plus que les attentats les
catastrophes naturelles met en péril le
tourisme
moi j'ai pu vivre grâce au tourisme
aussi en indonésie j'ai vécu le
tremblement terre et tout ça en turquie
qui sont des moments très difficiles
aussi régalé au joli la turquie ça les
chiffres extraordinaires
il pense que la mer et le soleil à moins
de trois heures d'avion de l'europe
c'est un atout exceptionnel pour attirer
les touristes et oublier les attentats
du bardo marcus vient de sauver l'emploi
de 80 tunisiens qui ont retrouvé le
sourire
un peu d'espoir dans un pays où le
développement économique constitue l'un
des meilleur rempart contre l'intégrisme
et la violence politique
[Musique]
je